i want to know are there any crazy rugby
stories
about uh some footy bulk stories yeah
there's some crazy stories yeah well
what kind of what kind of stories you
want i don't know i just know the aussie
guys
i'll be honest with rugby league it's uh
my like i wear a bunch of grubs i'll be
honest
i mean
and uh i can say that because all my
friends all my friends are leaguing like
him i would obviously get on the piss
and mad mondays mad mondays this is what
you do on a mad monday so after your
like your grandfather or whatever the
end of the season you just go on a
massive bender okay and a proper bender
right like i mean like yeah going nuts
yeah but i mean i've done plenty of
stuff
i'll tell you
the leech one i don't know if i tell
them about the legs oh come on
i'll tell you it's now anyway so yeah
we're going all the way to the festival
so we're going to first of all again i
was the type of guy like i wasn't even
going to go i'll jump on the bus and
i'll come up with you and then i had a
couple of drinks i'm like oh [ __ ] it i'm
coming to the festival i wasn't dressed
for it or anyway and then we went there
we're all hanging a piss off the bus you
know you do it in the bush and we all
come out back in the bus with leeches on
our legs oh my god and like i was just
like what the hell everyone's got
leeches and then to me i'm already in a
state uh i swear it was like a half an
hour to an hour and i was already in a
state i'm just scaling drinks but uh
then i end up being like oh [ __ ] it so i
end up just eating it
take the leech off my lips but i
swallowed it whole oh my god so i
swallowed it whole and i was like
um you know and then i started get
thinking about i'm like wait a second
these things like suck your blood right
like
this [ __ ] in my gut sucking my
blood who knows what it's doing
right now
thinking [ __ ] what do i do i started
freaking out so i'm like maybe if i have
more alcohol
right exactly
alcohol so i was like i have more
spirits you know the main spirits
vodka skull and vodka thinking that the
alcohol would kill the the leech that's
in my guts just [ __ ] like that mate like
you don't even want to know these this
is my stories all right that one's mine
i'll tell you some other ones
but he's saying me i swear yeah
i believe you it's not you yeah yeah
definitely yeah
you mean you have you heard of the
bubbler no
[Laughter]
it's just a thing that rugby league
players do so it's just uh literally you
just piss in your mouth but you're doing
it
what are you
you know the water fountains yeah and
you know the water shoots up yeah we
call them bubblers
so you're like you're you know you're
drinking out of a bubble out of a water
fountain yeah so that's what they did i
didn't i didn't do this i swear but guys
on your team
with multiple mates this is where the
british sent you guys to australia yeah
[Laughter]
alex there's not a lot of black people
in australia
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
machine
yeah but i mean there was a guy that
like uh man i've seen him do all like
this guy's like he's eating pubes he
drank his own pierce and he done that
and then this guy just did it for the
fun and goes oh you've done that i'll do
all that at once so like he ended up
doing that eating poops drunk literally
all he had to do was drink a little bit
he drank the whole bottle of
of someone else's piss i think it was
but i mean you name a man some of the
[ __ ] you see on monday it's crazy even i
remember a guy that was drinking a beer
i'm still in this story off one of my
mates actually he's seen this yeah
someone else
so he uh he's he drank and then spewed
back into it drops it and then what are
the glasses again it's like they want to
top each other yeah so it's like going
like you know it's like a competition
any guy he looks at people he just gives
them a look of the
grabs the spew in the water no
and there he goes up
and then just walks off am i that's just
that way that's that's the oh my gosh
yeah so yeah it's uh you see some pretty
knowledge that's what the delete is my
story yeah the rest of i promise it
ain't my story
aboriginals wouldn't know
i totally understand the lockdowns now
it's like lock them up
and you don't even have to feed them
anyway you guys together you just eat
your own [ __ ] it's perfect
that is something that i haven't seen
though i haven't seen the you know one
or two oh there you go there's a couple
of look man there's many more trust me
yeah we're going to go over here
what's the
that we didn't even question him after
he did this okay go go go so he's like
um
was there and he's like sitting there
and uh again like this is because you
said you know the gay thing yeah so he's
there and he's like um
i don't even know what what happened but
i mean again random [ __ ] was on a mad
monday we're all all sitting on the
field totally absolutely cooked we're
all cooked and just sitting around the
corner uh like heaps of us on the grass
and on our chairs wherever yeah and then
uh one of the guys i know what happened
and then like i think he goes i can like
he literally goes
i can lick his dick and you just
couldn't say a [ __ ] thing about it
he goes on that straight i can lick his
[ __ ] used to say nothing about it
that's how straight i am and he's saying
this sort of stuff and i'm not lying it
goes and our mate just pulls his pants
there goes oh and then he's like i love
you
i'm telling you somebody should we see
that hey but do you wanna you wanna know
the worst part
you just wanna you just said it
the worst part was
there's a lot of rugby league players
watching begun yet yeah that's right
but the guy okay so they're sitting down
and he goes i'm so straight i could lick
his dick and you guys can't say anything
about it i don't know how that
conversation come about but it did and
what about this guy what about this guy
like was he in on it no he's just he's
the same he's oh yeah
i don't know how to tell ya
whatever
i believe you you know what i mean you
know it's like burning man yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was a pretty full-on and
mind you like that's a
a bender too you could imagine all night
as well like it's a
just gonna smell the best either but
would he like
you guys still don't believe me like was
he trying to do
other stuff again like he literally were
like oh do you got a point like i don't
i'm not i don't you didn't try to one-up
him though right no no no that's it
i don't try and one-up a lot of the guys
did anybody else you know try to to get
their dick clicked by that guy
i don't [ __ ] believe you these are
trying
the leaked story is mine but i mean i'm
happy to let you zoom in on that elite
story is kind of a bitch-ass story
somebody else i love this rugby [ __ ] man
bro
honestly
come over and i'll get yous on a mad
monday night
let's go
that's why we had to do this wednesday
yeah one day he was a little busy
do the rugby dudes like are they just at
the pub with everybody else or are they
such celebrities they can't just go out
um oh no they can go out you know that's
not too but i mean uh obviously it's
it's big it depends on which area you're
in yeah you're back home like uh where
we're from you know rugby league is
massive you know you go to melbourne and
not many people would like you know in
melbourne yeah and things like that
because it's more afl and yeah but i
mean they could go out obviously some
people will get photos but i mean yeah
yeah yeah yeah but i mean like yeah
but i mean like there's yeah you see
you've always [ __ ] up videos of rugby
league players getting caught out and
[ __ ] like you know what i mean
like we've got the bubbler is big like
in our role players like you know like
doing the bubble and it's caught on film
like you know what i mean just you know
they're getting can't they're getting
bent
from sports from pissing in their mouth
you know what i mean like
[Laughter]
what are you doing to me i found a photo
of the bubbler if you guys are
interested yeah i would like to see that
yeah right before you please
[Applause]
that's toad connie what a legend you
know the guy yes he's a famous rugby
leaguer he's a legend todd carney oh
yeah that's the guy he sat next to on
the bus oh dude that's his
[Applause]
you